son unité et le regard des soldats
ukrainien sur le terrain cet homme est
l'un des commandant d'une escadrille de
pilotes de drones ils opèrent à la fois
des drones de reconnaissance mais
également des drones armés mon précieux
- yves des evaux match et on travaille
jour et nuit on les observe
on détermine leur position précise
son vol et on frappe
parfois ils nous entendent parce que
certains drones dont un bruit
reconnaissable
quand ils entendent le bruit alors on
les voit courir paniquer puis se couche
et se cacher mais tous n'y a rien
si
son unité fabrique désormais ses propres
drones d'attaqué comme celui ci les
troupes russes dit-il se sont adaptés
travail
le manque d'équipements c'est notre
principal défaut
on doit reconnaître sa l'ennemi il
travaille beaucoup et ils sont bons sur
les contre-mesures la guerre
électronique moi j'encourage donc
presque tous les jours on perd du
matériel donc c'est pour ça qu'on
demande toujours du soutien
on a besoin et on voit arriver de
nouveaux équipements du monde entier
les vols quotidiens au tour de la
capitale confirme dit il des forces
russes à la peine
voit très bien ce qui se passe autour de
kiev il se protège et l'on voit que ça
commence à sentir le roussi pour
certains
ils sont parfois coupés de leur
ravitaillement notamment munitions en
nourriture et en carburant
salle et démoralisent mais c'est visible
une situation très différente sur le
front est son unité effectue chaque jour
plusieurs centaines de missions et lui
en est conscient il leur faudra tenir
sur la durée